so
when uh
when you make 500 million dollars and
your dad doesn't even put 15
into a special account for you
is it like
you made all this money and you didn't
even get to blow it yourself like other
people blew it well i mean that's 75
million dollars that was supposed to go
into my account
enough not not five
what i got
so uh when you so is there any ever any
like legal action against like your your
parents no because when the when all of
a sudden 2014
25 24 25 26 years i don't remember
exactly but
i get hit with a bankruptcy or liens and
they garnish my wages and i was like
broke i completely broke at the time
doing this off broadway show called the
fantastics for two years trying to just
rebuild my accountability as a you know
a performer
then they garnish my wages i only made
654 dollars a week 80 bucks a night and
then they garnished that and i only then
in new york city i was only making 312
dollars a week
and
and then my lawyer jan michael morris
was like
you know you're gonna probably get like
a chapter 11 or 13 or something like
that he says by the graces of god you'll
get a chapter seven but it's probably
not going to happen
which means i had to either pay 11
chapter 11 would be 25 cents on the
dollar chapter 13
is 50 cents on on the dollar that you
got to pay how much did you owe i owed
over 8 million
and from stemming from 2001 two and
three
damn so at eight when i was a little kid
at 600 a week on broadway that's a
lifetime to pay back
at that point i just was like i'm
screwed and i called my brother nick and
i asked him i said yo can i have fifteen
hundred dollars to retain jan
to start this bankruptcy thing and nick
was like oh you got to go to therapy
three times a week and you have to pay
for it yourself and i'm like uh i can
only make 300 a week what do you want me
to eat out of trash cans i said i
already have to wait outside of a deli
at 3am to wait for the guys to give me
bacon so like you know ma'am
um
and he said no my brother said no though
he was like no no you got to do this and
you say nah and i was like and he he
told me to rot in jail he hung up on me
and
ma'am
so and then and then and then i went to
the courts paid the money
got them taken care of on my own how did
you get the money
i ended up getting a bonus that month
for if i sold out the whole show for the
month i would get 30 000
so i got 30 000 and then i had to pay
for my sister's funeral and for my that
month and for my bankruptcy and
um we go in
and my my attorney general michael
morris was like hey you know all you
have to do is get a judgment against
your mom and dad they'll go to prison
you'll have to pay a dime i said i would
never do that to my parents so i don't
care what they've done wrong they've
given me this career this life
and i'm gonna do good things and i'm
gonna rebuild my career so i went to the
judge personally he's an incredible
litigator and i walked up told him my
story and the judge was like hey just
sign these papers and it's not on you
and i said nope
i told him right to his face i said i'll
pay the 50 cents on a dollar he goes
because you said that i'm giving you a
chapter 7. bam you have a full discharge
everything is getting paid off for you
for free you don't owe anything and you
don't have the credit score goes back up
to 700 because of what you just said to
me so just a clean wipe you down to just
because zero i
would i told the judge i would never put
my parents in prison did you ever talk
to your mom about it like did she
like what does she say about it like
about that error when all that money's
coming in and you know she's spending
she didn't really have the time to uh
account for it and do it because she was
with me and i was a little kid you know
i was pre-teen teen adult you know and
she was with me the whole time so it
wasn't it was my dad's job to handle the
finances not my mom's it was never her
fault yeah we're like dad three yachts
no i was like
yeah dude
thanks for watching that clip and if you
live in america there's a good chance
that this big badass tour bus is coming
to your town with my bucket list tour
what is it well it's an x-rated show
full of all the stuff that i would have
never have been allowed to do for
jackass and a lot of it is flagrantly
illegal so it's adults only and if you
live in any of these states then you
better go to stevo.com and check out my
tour schedule hurry up and get your
tickets too because it's selling out
everywhere
yeah dude
[Music]
yeah dude